The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT open courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's go.
So if you want to know the
subject of today's class,
it's A x = b.
I got started writing down
different possibilities
for A x = b, and I
got carried away.
It just appears all over the
place for different sizes,
different ranks, different
situations, nearly singular,
not nearly singular.
And the question is, what
do you do in each case?
So can I outline my
little two pages of notes
here, and then pick on
one or two of these topics
to develop today, and
a little more on Friday
about Gram-Schmidt?
So I won't do much, if
any, of Gram-Schmidt today,
but I will do the others.
So the problem is A x = b.
That problem has
come from somewhere.
We have to produce some
kind of an answer, x.
So I'm going from good to bad or
easy to difficult in this list.
Well, except for number 0,
which is an answer in all cases,
using the pseudo inverse
that I introduced last time.
So that deals with 0
eigenvalues and zero singular
values by saying
their inverse is also
0, which is kind of wild.
So we'll come back to the
meaning of the pseudo inverse.
But now, I want
to get real, here,
about different situations.
So number 1 is the
good, normal case,
when a person has a square
matrix of reasonable size,
reasonable condition,
a condition
number-- oh, the
condition number,
I should call it
sigma 1 over sigma n.
It's the ratio of the largest
to the smallest singular value.
And let's say that's within
reason, not more than 1,000
or something.
Then normal, ordinary
elimination is going to work,
and Matlab--
the command that would produce
the answer is just backslash.
So this is the normal case.
Now, the cases that follow
have problems of some kind,
and I guess I'm
hoping that this is
a sort of useful dictionary of
what to do for you and me both.
So we have this case here, where
we have too many equations.
So that's a pretty normal
case, and we'll think mostly
of solving by least
squares, which leads us
to the normal equation.
So this is standard, happens
all the time in statistics.
And I'm thinking in
the reasonable case,
that would be ex hat.
The solution A--
this matrix would be
invertible and reasonable size.
So backslash would still
solve that problem.
Backslash doesn't
require a square matrix
to give you an answer.
So that's the good case,
where the matrix is not
too big, so it's not
unreasonable to form
a transpose.
Now, here's the other extreme.
What's exciting for us is this
is the underdetermined case.
I don't have enough
equations, so I
have to put something more
in to get a specific answer.
And what makes it exciting
for us is that that's
typical of deep learning.
There are so many weights
in a deep neural network
that the weights
would be the unknowns.
Of course, it wouldn't
be necessarily linear.
It wouldn't be linear,
but still the idea's
the same that we
have many solutions,
and we have to pick one.
Or we have to pick an algorithm,
and then it will find one.
So we could pick the minimum
norm solution, the shortest
solution.
That would be an L2 answer.
Or we could go to L1.
And the big question that, I
think, might be settled in 2018
is, does deep learning and
the iteration from stochastic
gradient descent that
we'll see pretty soon--
does it go to the minimum L1?
Does it pick out an L1 solution?
That's really an
exciting math question.
For a long time, it
was standard to say
that these deep learning
AI codes are fantastic,
but what are they doing?
We don't know all the interior,
but we-- when I say we,
I don't mean I. Other
people are getting there,
and I'm going to tell you
as much as I can about it
when we get there.
So those are pretty
standard cases.
m = n, m greater than n, m
less than n, but not crazy.
Now, the second board will
have more difficult problems.
Usually, because they're
nearly singular in some way,
the columns are
nearly dependent.
So that would be the
columns in bad condition.
You just picked
a terrible basis,
or nature did, or somehow you
got a matrix A whose columns
are virtually dependent--
almost linearly dependent.
The inverse matrix is
really big, but it exists.
Then that's when you go in,
and you fix the columns.
You orthogonalize columns.
Instead of accepting the
columns A1, A2, up to An
of the given matrix,
you go in, and you
find orthonormal vectors
in that column space
and orthonormal basis Q1 to Qn.
And the two are connected
by Gram-Schmidt.
And the famous matrix
statement of Gram-Schmidt
is here are the columns of
A. Here are the columns of Q,
and there's a triangular
matrix that connects the two.
So that is the central
topic of Gram-Schmidt
in that idea of orthogonalizing.
It just appears everywhere.
It appears all over course
6 in many, many situations
with different names.
So that, I'm sort of saving
a little bit until next time,
and let me tell you why.
Because just the organization
of Gram-Schmidt is interesting.
So Gram-Schmidt, you
could do the normal way.
So that's what I teach in 18.06.
Just take every
column as it comes.
Subtract off projections
onto their previous stuff.
Get it orthogonal to
the previous guys.
Normalize it to
be a unit vector.
Then you've got that column.
Go on.
So I say that
again, and then I'll
say it again two days from now.
So Gram-Schmidt, the idea
is you take the columns--
you say the second
orthogonal vector, Q2,
will be some combination
of columns 1 and 2,
orthogonal to the first.
Lots to do.
And there's another order,
which is really the better order
to do Gram-Schmidt,
and it allows
you to do column pivoting.
So this is my topic
for next time,
to see Gram-Schmidt
more carefully.
Column pivoting means
the columns might not
come in a good order, so you
allow yourself to reorder them.
We know that you have to
do that for elimination.
In elimination,
it would be rows.
So elimination, we
would have the matrix A,
and we take the first row
as the first pivot row,
and then the second row,
and then the third row.
But if the pivot is too
small, then reorder the rows.
So it's row ordering that
comes up in elimination.
And Matlab just
systematically says, OK,
that's the pivot
that's coming up.
The third pivot comes
up out of the third row.
But Matlab says look down
that whole third column
for a better pivot,
a bigger pivot.
Switch to a row exchange.
So there are lots of
permutations then.
You end up with something
there that permutes the rows,
and then that gets
factored into LU.
So I'm saying something
about elimination
that's just sort
of a side comment
that you would
never do elimination
without considering the
possibility of row exchanges.
And then this is Gram-Schmidt
orthogonalization.
So this is the LU world.
Here is the QR
world, and here, it
happens to be columns
that you're permuting.
So that's coming.
This is section 2.2, now.
But there's more.
2.2 has quite a bit
in it, including
number 0, the pseudo
inverse, and including
some of these things.
Actually, this will
be also in 2.2.
And maybe this is what I'm
saying more about today.
So I'll put a little
star for today, here.
What do you do?
So this is a case where the
matrix is nearly singular.
You're in danger.
It's inverse is
going to be big--
unreasonably big.
And I wrote inverse
problems there,
because inverse problem
is a type of problem
with an application that
you often need to solve
or that engineering and
science have to solve.
So I'll just say a
little more about that,
but that's a typical application
in which you're near singular.
Your matrix isn't
good enough to invert.
Well, of course, you
could always say,
well, I'll just use
the pseudo inverse,
but numerically,
that's like cheating.
You've got to get in there
and do something about it.
So inverse problems
would be examples.
Actually, as I
write that, I think
that would be a
topic that I should
add to the list of potential
topics for a three week
project.
Look up a book on
inverse problems.
So what do I mean by
an inverse problem?
I'll just finish this thought.
What's an inverse problem?
Typically, you know about
a system, say a network,
RLC network, and you give
it a voltage or current.
You give it an input,
and you find the output.
You find out what current
flows, what the voltages are.
But inverse problems are--
suppose you know the response
to different voltages.
What was the network?
You see the problem?
Let me say it again.
Discover what the network
is from its outputs.
So that turns out to
typically be a problem that
gives nearly singular matrices.
That's a difficult problem.
A lot of nearby networks would
give virtually the same output.
So you have a matrix
that's nearly singular.
It's got singular
values very close to 0.
What do you do then?
Well, the world of
inverse problems
thinks of adding a penalty term,
some kind of a penalty term.
When I minimize this
thing just by itself,
in the usual way, A transpose,
it has a giant inverse.
The matrix A is
badly conditioned.
It takes vectors almost to 0.
So that A transpose has
got a giant inverse,
and you're at risk of losing
everything to round off.
So this is the solution.
You could call it
a cheap solution,
but everybody uses it.
So I won't put that
word on videotape.
But that sort of resolves
the problem, but then
the question--
it shifts the problem,
anyway, to what number--
what should be the penalty?
How much should you penalize it?
You see, by adding that, you're
going to make it invertible.
And if you make this bigger,
and bigger, and bigger,
it's more and more
well-conditioned.
It resolves the trouble, here.
And like today, I'm going
to do more with that.
So with that, I'll stop
there and pick it up
after saying something
about 6 and 7.
I hope this is helpful.
It was helpful to me, certainly,
to see all these possibilities
and to write down
what the symptom is.
It's like a linear
equation doctor.
Like you look for the symptoms,
and then you propose something
at CVS that works
or doesn't work.
But you do something about it.
So when the problem is too big--
up to now, the problems have
not been giant out of core.
But now, when it's too big--
maybe it's still in
core but really big--
then this is in 2.1.
So that's to come back to.
The word I could
have written in here,
if I was just going to write
one word, would be iteration.
Iterative methods, meaning
you take a step like--
the conjugate radiant method is
the hero of iterative methods.
And then that name
I erased is Krylov,
and there are other
names associated
with iterative methods.
So that's the section
that we passed over just
to get rolling, but
we'll come back to.
So then that one, you
never get the exact answer,
but you get closer and closer.
If the iterative
method is successful,
like conjugate gradients, you
get pretty close, pretty fast.
And then you say,
OK, I'll take it.
And then finally, way
too big, like nowhere.
You're not in core.
Just your matrix-- you just
have a giant, giant problem,
which, of course, is
happening these days.
And then one way to
do it is your matrix.
You can't even look
at the matrix A,
much less A transpose.
A transpose would
be unthinkable.
You couldn't do it in a year.
So randomized linear
algebra has popped up,
and the idea there,
which we'll see,
is to use probability
to sample the matrix
and work with your samples.
So if the matrix is way too big,
but not too crazy, so to speak,
then you could sample
the columns and the rows,
and get an answer
from the sample.
See, if I sample the columns
of a matrix, I'm getting--
so what does sampling mean?
Let me just complete this, say,
add a little to this thought.
Sample a matrix.
So I have a giant matrix A.
It might be sparse, of course.
I didn't distinguish
over their sparse things.
That would be another thing.
So if I just take random
X's, more than one,
but not the full n
dimensions, those
will give me random guys
in the column space.
And if the matrix
is reasonable, it
won't take too many to have a
pretty reasonable idea of what
that column space is like, and
with it's the right hand side.
So this world of
randomized linear algebra
has grown because it had to.
And of course, any
statement can never
say for sure you're going
to get the right answer,
but using the inequalities
of probability,
you can often say that the
chance of being way off
is less than 1 in 2 to
the 20th or something.
So the answer is, in reality,
you get a good answer.
That is the end of
this chapter, 2.4.
So this is all
chapter 2, really.
The iterative method's in 2.1.
Most of this is in 2.2.
Big is 2.3, and then really
big is randomized in 2.4.
So now, where are we?
You were going to let me know
or not if this is useful to see.
But you sort of see what
are real life problems.
And of course, we're highly,
especially interested
in getting to the deep
learning examples, which
are underdetermined.
Then when you're
underdetermined,
you've got many solutions,
and the question
is, which one is a good one?
And in deep learning,
I just can't
resist saying another word.
So there are many solutions.
What to do?
Well, you pick some algorithm,
like steepest descent, which
is going to find a solution.
So you hope it's a good one.
And what does a good one
mean verses a not good one?
They're all solutions.
A good one means that when
you apply it to the test data
that you haven't yet seen,
it gives good results
on the test data.
The solution has
learned something
from the training data, and
it works on the test data.
So that's the big
question in deep learning.
How does it happen that you,
by doing gradient descent
or whatever algorithm--
how does that algorithm
bias the solution?
It's called implicit bias.
How does that algorithm
bias a solution
toward a solution
that generalizes,
that works on test data?
And you can think
of algorithms which
would approach a solution that
did not work on test data.
So that's what you
want to stay away from.
You want the ones that work.
So there's very deep
math questions there,
which are kind of new.
They didn't arise
until they did.
And we'll try to save some
of what's being understood.
Can I focus now on,
for probably the rest
of today, this case, when the
matrix is nearly singular?
So you could apply
elimination, but it
would give a poor result.
So one solution is the SVD.
I haven't even mentioned the
SVD, here, as an algorithm,
but of course, it is.
The SVD gives you an answer.
Boy, where should
that have gone?
Well, the space
over here, the SVD.
So that produces-- you have
A = U sigma V transposed,
and then A inverse is V
sigma inverse U transposed.
So we're in the case, here.
We're talking about number 5.
Nearly singular, where
sigma has some very small,
singular values.
Then sigma inverse has some
very big singular values.
So you're really
in wild territory
here with very big inverses.
So that would be
one way to do it.
But this is a way to
regularize the problem.
So let's just pay
attention to that.
So suppose I minimize the sum
of A x minus b squared and delta
squared times the
size of x squared.
And I'm going to
use the L2 norm.
It's going to be a least
squares with penalty,
so of course, it's
the L2 norm here, too.
Suppose I solve
that for a delta.
For some, I have to
choose a positive delta.
And when I choose
a positive delta,
then I have a solvable problem.
Even if this goes to 0,
or A does crazy things,
this is going to keep
me away from singular.
In fact, what equation
does that lead to?
So that's a least squares
problem with an extra penalty
term.
So it would come, I suppose.
Let's see, if I write
the equations A delta I,
x equals b 0, maybe that is
the least squares equation--
the usual, normal equation--
for this augmented system.
Because what's the error here?
This is the new big A--
A star, let's say.
X equals-- this is the new b.
So if I apply least squares
to that, what do I do?
I minimize the sum of squares.
So least squares would
minimize A x minus b squared.
That would be from
the first components.
And delta squared x squared
from the last component, which
is exactly what we
said we were doing.
So in a way, this
is the equation
that the penalty
method is solving.
And one question, naturally,
is, what should delta be?
Well, that question's
beyond us, today.
It's a balance of
what you can believe,
and how much noise is in
the system, and everything.
That choice of delta--
what we could ask
is a math question.
What happens as delta goes to 0?
So suppose I solve this problem.
Let's see, I could
write it differently.
What would be the
equation, here?
This part would give
us the A transpose,
and then this part would
give us just the identity,
x equals A transpose b, I think.
Wouldn't that be?
So really, I've written here--
what that is is A
star transpose A star.
This is least squares on
this gives that equation.
So all of those are equivalent.
All of those would be
equivalent statements
of what the penalized problem
is that you're solving.
And then the question is, as
delta goes to 0, what happens?
Of course, something.
When delta goes to 0, you're
falling off the cliff.
Something quite
different is suddenly
going to happen, there.
Maybe we could even understand
this question with a 1
by 1 matrix.
I think this section
starts with a 1 by 1.
Suppose A is just a number.
Maybe I'll just put that
on this board, here.
Suppose A is just a number.
So what am I going
to call that number?
Just 1 by 1.
Let me call it sigma,
because it's certainly
the leading singular value.
So what's my equation
that I'm solving?
A transpose A would be sigma
squared plus delta squared, 1
by 1, x--
should I give some
subscript here?
I should, really,
to do it right.
This is the solution
for a given delta.
So that solution will exist.
Fine.
This matrix is
certainly invertible.
That's positive
semidefinite, at least.
semidefinite, and then what
about delta squared I?
It is positive
definite, of course.
It's just the identity
with a factor.
So this is a positive
definite matrix.
I certainly have a solution.
And let me keep going
on this 1 by 1 case.
This would be A transpose.
A is just a sigma.
I think it's just sigma b.
So A is 1 by 1, and there
are two cases, here--
Sigma bigger than 0,
or sigma equals 0.
And in either case, I just
want to know what's the limit.
So the answer x--
let me just take
the right hand side.
Well, that's fine.
Am I computing OK?
Using the penalize thing on a
1 by 1 problem, which you could
say is a little bit small--
so solving this equation or
equivalently minimizing this,
so here, I'm finding
the minimum of--
A was sigma x minus b squared
plus delta squared x squared.
You see it's just 1 by 1?
Just a number.
And I'm hoping that calculus
will agree with linear algebra
here, that if I find
the minimum of this--
so let me write it out.
Sigma squared x squared and
delta squared x squared,
and then minus 2 sigma xb,
and then plus b squared.
And now, I'm going to find
the minimum, which means
I'd set the derivative to 0.
So I get 2 sigma squared
and 2 delta squared.
I get a two here,
and this gives me
the x derivative as 2 sigma b.
So I get a 2 there, and I'm OK.
I just cancel both 2s,
and that's the equation.
So I can solve that equation.
X is sigma over sigma
squared plus delta squared b.
So it's really that quantity.
I want to let delta go to 0.
So again, what am I doing here?
I'm taking a 1 by 1
example just to see
what happens in the
limit as delta goes to 0.
What happens?
So I just have to look at that.
What is the limit of that
thing in a circle, as delta
goes to 0?
So I'm finding out for
a 1 by 1 problem what
a penalized least squares
problem, ridge regression,
all over the place--
what happens?
So what happens to that
number as delta goes to 0?
1 over sigma.
So now, let delta go to 0.
So that approaches 1 over
sigma, because delta disappears.
Sigma over sigma
squared, 1 over sigma.
So it approaches the
inverse, but what's
the other possibility, here?
The other possibility
is that sigma is 0.
I didn't say whether this
matrix, this 1 by 1 matrix,
was invertible or not.
If sigma is not 0, then
I go to 1 over sigma.
If sigma is really small,
it will take a while.
Delta will have to get small,
small, small, even compared
to sigma, until finally,
that term goes away,
and I just have 1 over sigma.
But what if sigma is 0?
Sorry to get excited about 0.
Who would get excited about 0?
So this is the case when
this is 1 over sigma,
if sigma is positive.
And what does it
approach if sigma is 0?
0!
Because this is 0,
the whole problem
was like disappeared, here.
The sigma was 0.
Here is a sigma.
So anyway, if sigma is 0, then
I'm getting 0 all the time.
But I have a decent
problem, because the delta
squared is there.
I have a decent problem
until the last minute.
My problem falls apart.
Delta goes to 0, and I
have a 0 equals 0 problem.
I'm lost.
But the point is the
penalty kept me positive.
It kept me with his
delta squared term
until the last critical moment.
It kept me positive
even if that was 0.
If that is 0, and this is 0,
I still have something here.
I still have a problem to solve.
And what's the limit then?
So 1 over sigma if
sigma is positive.
And what's the answer if
sigma is not positive?
It's 0.
Just tell me.
I'm getting 0.
I get 0 all the way, and
I get 0 in the limit.
And now, let me just ask,
what have I got here?
What is this sudden bifurcation?
Do I recognize this?
The inverse in the
limit as delta goes to 0
is either 1 over sigma,
if that makes sense,
or it's 0, which is
not like 1 over sigma.
1 over sigma-- as
sigma goes to 0,
this thing is getting
bigger and bigger.
But at sigma equals 0, it's 0.
You see, that's a really
strange kind of a limit.
Now, it would be over there.
What have I found
here, in this limit?
Say it again, because
that was exactly right.
The pseudo inverse.
So this system-- choose
delta greater than 0,
then delta going to 0.
The solution goes to
the pseudo inverse.
That's the key fact.
When delta is
really, really small,
then this behaves in
a pretty crazy way.
If delta is really, really
small, then sigma is bigger,
or it's 0.
If it's bigger, you go this way.
If it's 0, you go that way.
So that's the message,
and this is penalized.
These squares, as the penalty
gets smaller and smaller,
approaches the correct answer,
the always correct answer,
with that sudden split
between 0 and not 0
that we associate with
the pseudo inverse.
Of course, in a
practical case, you're
trying to find the resistances
and inductions in a circuit
by trying the circuit, and
looking at the output b,
and figuring out what input.
So the unknown x is the
unknown system parameters.
Not the voltage and current, but
the resistance, and inductance,
and capacitance.
I've only proved that
in the 1 by 1 case.
You may say that's
not much of a proof.
In the 1 by 1 case, we can see
it happen in front of our eyes.
So really, a step I
haven't taken here
is to complete that
to any matrix A.
So that the statement then.
That's the statement.
So that's the statement.
For any matrix A, this matrix,
A transpose A plus delta
squared inverse
times A transpose--
that's the solution
matrix to our problem.
That's what I wrote
down up there.
I take the inverse
and pop it over there.
That approaches A plus,
the pseudo inverse.
And that's what we just
checked for 1 by 1.
For 1 by 1, this
was sigma over sigma
squared plus delta squared.
And it went either to
1 over sigma or to 0.
It split in the limit.
It shows that limits
can be delicate.
The limit-- as delta
goes to 0, this thing
is suddenly discontinuous.
It's this number
that is growing,
and then suddenly, at
0, it falls back to 0.
Anyway, that would
be the statement.
Actually, statisticians
discovered the pseudo inverse
independently of the linear
algebra history of it,
because statisticians
did exactly that.
To regularize the problem,
they introduced a penalty
and worked with this matrix.
So statisticians were
the first to think
of that as a natural thing
to do in a practical case--
add a penalty.
So this is adding a
penalty, but remember
that we stayed with L2 norms,
staying with L2, least squares.
We could ask, what happens?
Suppose the penalty
is the L1 norm.
I'm not up to do this today.
Suppose I minimize that.
Maybe I'll do L2, but I'll do
the penalty guy in the L1 norm.
I'm certainly not
an expert on that.
Or you could even
think just that power.
So that would have a name.
A statistician invented this.
It's called the Lasso in the
L1 norm, and it's a big deal.
Statisticians like the
L1 norm, because it
gives sparse solutions.
It gives more genuine
solutions without a whole lot
of little components
in the answer.
So this was an important step.
Let me just say again where
we are in that big list.
The two important ones
that I haven't done yet
are these iterative
methods in 2.1.
So that's like conventional
linear algebra,
just how to deal
with a big matrix,
maybe with some
special structure.
That's what numerical
linear algebra is all about.
And then Gram-Schmidt
with or without pivoting,
which is a workhorse
of numerical computing,
and I think I better
save that for next time.
So this is the one I
picked for this time.
And we saw what happened in L2.
Well, we saw it for 1 by 1.
Would you want to extend
to prove this for any A,
going beyond 1 by 1?
How would you prove
such a thing for any A?
I guess I'm not going to do it.
It's too painful, but
how would you do it?
You would use the SVD.
If you want to prove something
about matrices, about
any matrix, the SVD
is the best thing
you could have-- the
best tool you could have.
I can write this in
terms of the SVD.
I just plug-in A equals
whatever the SVD tells
me to put in there.
U sigma V transposed.
Plug it in there,
simplify it using the fact
that these are orthogonal.
If I have any good luck,
it'll get an identity
somewhere from there and an
identity somewhere from there.
And it will all simplify.
It will all diagonalize.
That's what the SVD really
does is turns my messy problem
into a problem about their
diagonal matrix, sigma
in the middle.
So I might as well put
sigma in the middle.
Yeah, why not?
Before we give up on it--
a special case of that, but
really, the genuine case
would be when A is sigma.
Sigma transpose sigma plus
delta squared I inverse times
sigma transpose approaches the
pseudo inverse, sigma plus.
And the point is the matrix
sigma here is diagonal.
Oh, I'm practically
there, actually.
Why am I close to being
able to read this off?
Well, everything
is diagonal here.
Diagonal, diagonal, diagonal.
And what's happening on
those diagonal entries?
So you had to take my word
that when I plugged in the SVD,
the U and the V got
separated out to the far left
and the far right.
And it was that that
stayed in the middle.
So it's really this
is the heart of it.
And say, well, that's
diagonal matrix.
So I'm just looking at what
happens on each diagonal entry,
and which problem is that?
The question of what's happening
on a typical diagonal entry
of this thing is what question?
The 1 by 1 case!
The 1 by 1, because each
entry in the diagonal
is not even noticing the others.
So that's the logic, and
it would be in the notes.
Prove it first for 1 by 1,
then secondly for diagonal.
This, and finally with A's,
and they're using the SVD with
and U and V transposed
to get out of the way
and bring us back to here.
So that's the
theory, but really, I
guess I'm thinking that far
the most important message
in today's lecture is in
this list of different types
of problems that appear
and different ways
to work with them.
And we haven't
done Gram-Schmidt,
and we haven't done iteration.
So this chapter is a survey of--
well, more than a survey of
what numerical linear algebra
is about.
And I haven't done random, yet.
Sorry, that's coming, too.
So three pieces
are still to come,
but let's take the last two
minutes off and call it a day.